this is Joo podcast number 409 with Echo
Charles and me Joo willink good evening
Eko good
evening sometimes I want to take you by
your shoulders and Shake you you've got
to open your eyes how long will it take
you running through life blind what a
waste shut down and neutralized what a
case what happened what happened to you
what's going on what's going on with you
someday becomes yesterday your life goes
and crawls away you walking hand in hand
with a death
trip you can't even feel the power in
its
[Music]
grip and those right there are the
lyrics from a song called wreckage or
wreck age there's a hyphen in there by a
group called The Rollins band off the
lifetime album
which was the band Rollins band Led by
Henry Rollins the singer from Black Flag
one of my favorite bands as a kid
especially by the way Black Flag my War
side two that was on my record player
for I don't know probably 18 months to
two years straight that song though from
the Rollins band album had a big impact
me on me and that album had a big impact
on me it came out in 19
1987 it was sort
of one of the bricks in the path I guess
you might say you know you know the Pink
Floyd song it's Another Brick in the
Wall well I've been putting bricks in
the path okay this this album this song
definitely put some bricks in the path
for
me and it's amazing really that people
can go through life blind how they can
slip down the slope and get
neutralized and be caught in the grip of
something without even feeling the power
that's controlling
them and I think Echo Charles you
recently recognized you were being a
little bit neutralized you were being
inhibited by
alcohol and when you recognize that you
took control you squared some things
away and I think that your story over
the past few months and your thoughts
and your
methodology for how you
executed might help a lot of people so
let's get into
it let's what is your history with
alcohol where does it start when you
were a kid what what about your parents
was there alcohol in the house what's
going on yeah so there was alcohol in
the house but we hardly ever saw it so
it was like uh so my mom never really
drank at all but then my dad was like
the super social dude so he would
like he'd like after work he'd always
bring us with him you know for for the
most part yeah like after work he'd go
to these beach parties with his friends
and they weren't huge parties they were
just hanging out with their friends
basically and yeah he drinking stuff and
you figure how old is your dad at this
point uh probably in his 30s maybe yeah
so you figure well he was 33 when we
were born so you know yeah 40s like my
age is yeah going down down to the beach
yeah having a couple beverages with the
voice yeah which you know there's no you
know we grew up on kaai so it's like
that's just how so it's not like it
wasn't a big deal you know kids running
around and we weren't only kid so you
know at the Pavilion you know by the
beach or whatever so and my dad was the
kind where like um you couldn't tell he
was junk you know how some people you
can tell they just night and like they
switch and you can tell they're junk in
whatever way their behavior their their
well let's break that down a little bit
some people get angry right they want to
fight everybody some people get silly
They're laughing at everything some
people they get all slurry and kind of
lose their Moto skill motor skills yeah
uh I can tell you when when I used to
drink a lot I would just be more of me
yeah I would just be like an amplified
me yeah and that's was it's fun but it's
not really like one of the best
long-term not a long-term thinker yeah
and so your dad was one of these dudes
that would be like you could barely even
tell that he's drunk type thing yeah or
that he's drinking you couldn't tell
like I and then again I was a kid so I
don't know but he would not act
different and maybe if there was
something different I didn't notice kind
of pattern you know kind of a thing and
then what would help and I'm thinking
back I remember this I would be like oh
Dad have you ever been drunk before and
he was like no I don't get drunk he
would say that even though he does get J
but he would say that you know I don't
know if that was a tactic or what but
yeah it was like fullon he didn't act
different at all meanwhile I see other
people acting different like they would
get I I saw like people get in fights
and I seen a guy like stab a guy in the
arm and like all this stuff or whatever
and he's like oh yeah they don't know
how to control the alcohol you know that
kind of stuff you thought that no that's
what my dad would say say you know
sometimes where like if someone's
showing out or something like that um
they're like yeah they're just drunk or
whatever kind of a thing and I was like
okay well you know alcohol can do all
this stuff but for some reason either my
dad doesn't drink a lot or you know it
just doesn't affect him so it was like
that and then but every once in a while
like I'd find find like a 40 oun in his
truck half half gone you know like that
kind but I didn't notice any any of the
effects though nothing like that my mom
would mention it like oh Dad's drinking
or whatever but I wouldn't see it so I
didn't know what she was talking about
like whatever mhm so that was kind of it
really so what when did you start
drinking when you were a kid no like not
when we were a kid actually me and my
brother Jade we didn't drink and it was
like kind of you know we played Sports
and stuff like that but even through
high school when everyone else started
kind of drinking and partying we were
like kind of like it was like a like a
badge of honor kind of a thing where
it's like yeah we don't drink or do
drugs nothing like that in fact we we
had this newspaper article when we went
to college and they were like you know
interviewing us or whatever and they
were like oh yeah what would you want to
like what message would you send off to
people about yourself that you'd kind of
you know want want people to know or
whatever like oh that we don't drink or
do drugs and never will that's what it
said in the spirit damn look at you
getting I didn't know you were so famous
no no well back in the day back in the
yeah no I mean we were we were playing
football so you know football's kind of
a thing you kind of Hometown Heroes huh
a little bit you know do most of the
guys that play football in Hawaii are
they from Hawaii or do people come from
freaking Nebraska and stuff too yeah
yeah at uh University Hawai no no no
yeah everybody so like some people from
Hawaii and then some people from the
mainland for sure but is it kind of like
if you're from Hawaii you're sort of a
HomeTown hero type thing yeah because we
don't have NFL in Hawai or we don't have
a pro team in Hawaii so uh is kind of
the the top in the state you know and
we're kind of isolated so yeah it's a
little I think it's a little bit more
heightened I'd think like something I
mean other some towns are like that as
well but yeah for for sure I would say
being a football player in Hawaii like
especially when you go to uh it's like a
thing for sure did you guys ever get in
any trouble with the kids that were
drinking no no never did people peer
pressure you and what did you say not
really I no no I I never felt any peer
pressure check this out as a
tactic isn't it easier with the peer
pressure to say I don't drink than to be
like well not right now and well well I
guess I'm not really drinking tonight
yeah I think so just be like no I don't
drink I think if you have and now that
I'm thinking of about this clearly as an
adult if you have something else going
on that's like noticeably at least a
little bit successful and then you say I
don't drink it it kind of you know
people kind of put two and two together
like okay like that makes sense you know
kind of a thing and we were always into
sports and like working out and stuff
and we weren't the only ones but that
was it seemed like that was kind of a
thing like we were obviously on like
this path you know and then so we're
like yeah we don't drink so I don't
remember any of our and I had some peer
pressuring friends too by the way Jeremy
treskin
yeah and you know he drank a little bit
you know like whatever he was just like
normal um and yeah I don't remember him
peer pressuring us to drink he'd peer
pressure us into doing a bunch of other
stuff but never really drinking okay so
he knew that that was a futile effort
because you guys had a hard stance
against it that's what it felt like yeah
okay and then what about you get to
College how'd that go did you enter into
the drinking realm into college nope so
it was like that didn't move me either
way college and freedom now and all that
stuff so we actually there's at uh
there's like this dorm I think it called
el Lima and it's like there's no
drinking allowed it's a non like
drinking no drugs dorm El Lima that's
what it was called IM Lima
so even if you have a beer like a closed
beer or if you went shopping and you had
a beer that you're going to give to your
friend or something and it was in the
dorm you would get busted for I think
you'd get like kicked out of the dorm so
it was like that where it was like a
non-drinking dorm and we stayed there
for I want to say like I don't know two
semesters or two years what did was it
kind of nerdish cuz I mean you know
sometimes it's like not drinking is
associated with being kind of a dork or
a nerd yeah and now you take all the
people that don't drink cuz some people
that don't drink they don't drink cuz
they're getting jacked or they don't
drink cuz they're a freaking straight
edge hardcore kid or whatever and but
then you also get people that don't
drink maybe because they're a little bit
nerdy yeah and they don't they're not
social of socially awkward and now they
put them all together what was going on
in El Lima what was going down tell me
what's up I don't know me put it this
way if it was I never felt any of that I
never felt that people thought I was a
nerd or nothing like that I just figured
that's just how cuz there was other
people stay at that dorm so would you
say if you took a cross-section of el
Lima dorm yeah and you looked at all the
people it would seem like just regular
like a normal cross-section of a normal
college dorm or would you say yeah no
you're right it kind of lean I think
think you're
right a little bit yeah it was lean
thinking back now I can notice oh wait
there was a lot of people who are really
into the academics and really not really
trying to avoid the distractions of the
party um aspect of college for sure
thinking back but um but I didn't feel
it at the time at all and so did you
stay in the storm the whole time you
were in college no what
happened I think you know I think the
Curiosity kind of gets the better of you
overall where you know you're around
people and you know parties and stuff
like that and everyone's like having so
much fun and still getting good grades
and we're playing football and stuff
like that and a lot of people pretty
much everyone pretty much there was a
handful of people who didn't drink or do
drug but pretty much everyone else drank
too on the team and they're still doing
great in football and all this stuff so
so the the idea of drinking being this
big detriment in your life started to
get normalized a little bit drinking
became normalized more normalized and it
started to kind of shed some light on
the idea how true or not true it is it
shed some light on the idea that I think
this whole being a non-drinker thing was
more just like a cool thing to say and
do for the like the novelty you know
because ultimately it's just not even a
deal it's not a big deal at all and then
so you kind of mix all that stuff
together and then you know we curious
when you would drink what kind of
drinking were you doing were you a dude
like you know you see the college kids
that are just slamming handles of vodka
yeah doing the whole College thing whole
thing yeah col blackout drunk scenarios
I never was that no no no no so in
college you figure cuz I'll tell you
what like in the SEAL Teams there's a
whole another freaking and I guess the
military at large there's a level of
drinking it's probably
comparable it's it's in the realm of
like college type drinking blackout
throwing up alcohol poisoning getting
your stomach drinking games dring
competitions like there's a level of
stupidity that goes down in the 18 to
20 22 24 25 you know age group yeah this
is when people die yeah this is when
people fall out of Windows this is when
people die of alcohol poisoning drown in
their own puke uh just all kinds of
horrible things happen yeah and it comes
like that age group 18 to like I said 23
24 you know hopefully by the time you're
25 you're not slamming handles of
vodka but I think the military is
probably more hardcore I think it is too
I think it is too the other thing that's
well there's a bunch of things that make
it that way too number one you have a
paycheck yeah so like a college kid like
you're a little bit concerned about your
money you know you're a little bit
concerned about your money in the
military you're like yo I'm getting
another I'm getting more money in two
weeks so the money I've got for right
now is for
tonight and we're going to get it and
there's a whole element of like we're
going to die anyways right yes that's
what you know I came to grips with I was
talking to Peter AA when he came on the
podcast last time like you have an
element when you're in the SEAL Teams
even in the '90s there's no war going on
but you're skydiving you're freaking
diving you're locking out of submarines
like people die and so at some point in
your head you
either believe that you could die or you
at least use as a rationalization to
like just get crazy yeah like at least
some part of you is well you know this
might I could die tomorrow doing a
Skydive so we're going to have a good
time tonight so you have that whole
thing going on you got a paycheck you
got a possible death in the near future
Y and you got a bunch of friends and the
other thing that's weird oh this is
probably the biggest one you know how
when you go to college you're free for
the first time mhm well that happens on
a weekly basis in the military you were
like in the field and you were like
couldn't do anything or you were in the
barracks and then the weekend comes and
we're do whatever we want let's go that
totally makes there's all kinds of dumb
going on going down in the military
so I think it is next level slly Next
Level and look I've seen the college
kids give it a run for the money you
know what I mean they they go yeah it
feels like there's a different um like
dynamic as far as like what what
drinking is kind of centered around so
like military has this just general
feeling of hardc coreness to it where
like you know you're dealing with guns
and real bullets and like all this real
real stuff kind of on the hardcore part
of the spectrum and then
um and then it's like the stress
reliever I guess you could say and like
just and if you're going to do something
like it better be kind of Hardcore it
better be kind of badass right in
college is not like that it's more about
like the fun and the party and the
freaking you know the freedom and the
kind of we're wild yes but not like let
me ask you this did you football players
ever just like drink by yourselves as a
group uh yeah yeah yeah drinking beers
or whatever that but it that was
different though that's different that's
just more like you're just cruising
drinking beers not getting hammered and
woo partying and pound shot we're not
part you know taking shots yeah that's
when you get isolated elements with
alcohol with no possibility like a lot
of it let's face it in the military and
then as a Young Man a lot of the
drinking is centered around going to
find women right you're going have to
find girls meat girls all that we're
going to a party we're going to a bar
we're going to a club all this other
stuff in the military sometimes there's
no not you're not even doing that you're
just literally getting drunk and
Wrecking yourself for no reason yeah no
I don't think yeah I don't think that's
not in my experience anyway but when you
so you were drinking hard no well no not
really yeah kind of I mean no harder
than anyone else I just thought it was
really fun you know like the first time
I ever drank I was like bro I have no
idea how people can sustain this because
beer tastes like really bad if you if
you never drank and then TR I drink a
beer even like a super light one without
like that much beer taste you're like
bro The Taste itself is jamming you up
you know the more you drink and then I
remember thinking man I wish beer tasted
like Mountain Dew because getting
hammered kind of it was cool but the
taste is holding me back from the fun I
could be having kind of a feeling you
know and I remember I would always like
chew gum or like whatever but no I
wouldn't drink that hard but when you
don't drink and you're new to drinking
it doesn't take a lot you know but it
was it was just more about the fun and
stuff like that a new found fun you know
and and you just viewed it as now it
went from something that you didn't do
but now it's just kind of a normalized
thing that has become part of your life
no big deal drink oh we're going to go
out we're going to have fun we're going
to drink all good loosen things up a
little bit provide a little social
lubricant right okay yeah and we did
dumb stuff for sure and I did dumb stuff
for sure
I.E like you know you sneak into like
private property and like have the party
there I got in trouble for um in
inciting like what they said was a kind
of a riot which wasn't right that was an
exaggeration but it was basically a big
party was going on there was two parties
going on in these high-rise dorms and
they both got shut down cuz they're too
L there was like a band in there and
stuff it was FL it was a flagrant party
it wasn't my party I was just part of it
it was my friend's one and then so that
you know everyone comes shuts it down
and everyone has to all come this is
like hundreds of people they all come
down and now they're in the courtyard in
the bot on the bottom floor and it's
like no one wants to end the party it's
kind of early you know and no one wants
to end the party but they don't have
anywhere to go and you can't hang in the
courtyard but technically as an
individual you can't see I I kind of
formulated my little argument as an
individual you can hang out in the
courtyard
so as a group you can't but as an
individual you can so I was going and so
all the there security and then the Ra's
resent advisers I think whatever they're
saying hey you guys can't hang here
right hundreds of people and I knew most
of them so I was just going around
saying hey you don't have to leave and
i' I'd say that argument where it's like
you can stay here like there's no rule
against staying right here you know we
can't have a party but if you just say
you're I'm just here cruising by myself
and I don't you know I'm not with them
kind of an idea you can't go and I was
right
so when you drink you become an adamant
debater that was one of the one of the
things for sure but it worked though so
no one left and more security would come
more security would come then the cops
finally came and was like you guys all
do have to leave and then everyone left
and then I got in trouble for that big
time but yeah that was it was like that
kind of stuff like I wouldn't you know
you get into little fights and stuff
like that but it wasn't anything where I
wasn't getting arrested you tring
Jiu-Jitsu yet no you just knew a little
bit knew from the Hoist Gracie tapes and
stuff like that so actually we would do
little tournaments and little matches in
the gym but I did not I was not trained
in Jitsu at this point though and that's
how your college kind of normal College
still drinking is pretty normalized are
you're drinking weekends are you
drinking during the week at all not
during the week no just so you're just
drinking weekends y kind of no big deal
all right then you move out to San Diego
right after you get done with college
yeah and you get out here did you go
straight to work in the in the nightclub
industry yeah and so now it's alcohol
Centric the environment yes but I wasn't
I was still only drinking on like days
off kind of a thing like two days one
day two days a week and that's kind of
the the where you stayed for a while yes
was like okay did you drink hey you get
done working at 2:00 in the morning and
like you guys Clos the front door and
now we're going to pet you know every
not really like that every once in a
while yes if like let's say I worked on
a Saturday and I don't work on a Sunday
or whatever the days are and then you
know the the manager whatever cuz we're
all friends in there too so you know
we'd close up and then yes we'd have
like one drink two drinks you can't just
drink all the alcohol in the bar you
know it's like and plus you got to drive
home yeah you got to drive home you got
to you know like it's not party time and
it's late you're not going to you know I
mean although that probably happened you
know once or twice or whatever but
generally speaking no so you just have
one or two and that's it and again not
every day just cuz you're arounded every
day like I'm not drinking every day most
people not like that it's just on the
days off so you're still
kind of in a place where drinking is
sort of normal you're not really feeling
any negative impact you're having fun
not at all you're still working out
you're still doing normal stuff you're
not you haven't been arrested you
haven't gotten a DUI you don't feel the
need to drink every night so you're in a
pretty what we would say is a non
alcohol is not having a now look we
could drill down and be like oh yes we
could pick it apart but from your
perception at the time alcohol is not
having a negative impact on your life
that is correct and and here's why which
is is like something that like you kind
of go in and out of remembering this
idea that thinking back then even in
college where the reason it wasn't a
problem is because I I had other stuff
going on that was more important than
hanging out and partying or another way
to put it is alcohol didn't fit into the
more important things that I was doing
like it didn't fit it would always mess
it up so like you can't if you're into
your Fitness you know kind of a thing
being a young single guy in San Diego
whatever to and I was always always in
Fitness whatever but I was kind of into
it so if I'm drinking you can't work out
hung over like it's not sustainable you
know and I knew that and I was really
into like the working out process was
fun to me so I was like freck if you
work out it makes working out or if you
drink it's not fun to work out the next
day not at all no matter how much you
power through it it's not fun at all so
it's night and day so it was like it I
understood that these other things are
way more important than drinking no
matter how fun it gets these more things
these things in life are way more
important and drinking would just get in
the way so and that was always in the
back of my head not consciously but
that's how it felt you know like if
someone's like hey let's go out party
I'm like no I have like workout I work
you know all this stuff so it's safe to
say that you wouldn't be considered like
an alcoholic by standard definitions not
in the public definition I mean
medically yeah because of how much but
okay cuz they they would give you like a
thing in the military to judge if you're
an alcoholic or
not and and it would be like six
questions like do you drink to get drunk
do you ever black out do you have more
than what whatever and it'd be like it'd
be the you you'd answer them and then
it'd say if you answered yes to one of
these questions then you you could be
considered an alcoholic and most of the
guys in my platoons would just every one
of those would be a yes like yeah yeah
of course I blacked I blacked out you
know last night whatever so it was
almost like they judged it to the point
where it didn't mean anything yeah you
know what I mean yeah exactly it's like
oh everyone's just an alcoholic but it
sounds to me like you would have
actually answered no to most of those
questions I would have answered no to
most of them but I still would have been
Al because I would have answered one yes
to at least one of those and I I know I
do have to answer yes to a lot of the
ones that the doctor ask asks you you
know you have more than you know four
drinks or whatever per week and it's
like yeah I have more than four drinks
in one day and I drink more than once a
week you four drinks in one hour yeah
you know it's like I'm idiot yeah exact
okay so you're doing cool I mean
relatively speaking Rel this is not a
this is not causing negative impacts in
your life at this time again could you
have been better yes you know when I
look back at my life and I just think of
the financial
implications of drinking it's ridiculous
it's totally ridiculous yes it is
because when I on the SEAL Teams you
know we spent a lot of money yeah on
alcohol a lot of money on alcohol
and if I would have saved that money
invested that money bought something you
know house whatever like it would have
been just a totally different scenario I
mean we'd spend it was no factor to
spend four or 500 bucks a night in the
90s yeah you know in the early '90s go
out and spend 500 bucks oh like at the
bar yeah oh% cuz back in the day you
could only get $300 out of uh out of an
ATM yeah that's true and so I remember
I'd have to kind of preload the day
before to make sure I had like 600 bucks
for the for whatever we were going to do
and look that might include a taxi it
might include some some burgers or
whatever but most of it 3 400 of it
booze just like an idiot that's so
there's that and then time you know like
how much time did I spend drinking and
we spend drinking when we could have
been getting better at Guitar could have
been you know learning how to do a skill
that would be more valuable what sucks
is you know you're in the SEAL Teams
there's only these certain skills that
you care about that's it and I think you
just care about diving you like just
these things you care about and you can
do okay with them and you're pretty good
at him and actually in your platoon
you're like dude I'm you know we're all
the best and I'm pretty good even with
the best so I'm good yeah that's the
exactly the same my obviously not with
shooting and D but with the stuff that I
cared about it was drinking basically
was like second to all that stuff so I
could fit it in you know if you can get
five workouts a day or a week um get to
work on time do a good job at work not
get arrested and stuff like that you're
like you're kind of good to go so you
feel like you're good to go yeah okay so
then what what created the where you
started to drink a little bit more was
that when you got injured was that yep
yeah so this is years later so you
figure you live that lifestyle for five
six years five six 2001 four five yeah
five years is you know yeah just cre
like I would say I was not an anomaly as
far as drinking that's why I hate to say
it normal
because I wish normal was people didn't
drink but for in comparison with normal
humans you were kind of doing the normal
thing drinking on the weekends Friday
Saturday you know maybe if there was a
Sunday you know pool party you'd kick
back with a couple two three five
exactly seven exact right call it good
okay so we know where you're at and then
you tear your bicep is this the first
bicep that you tore yeah so and fast
forward cuz I got into Jiu-Jitsu which
was even more like hey no drink drinking
you know like kind of so and then I was
working out twice a day like doing all
this stuff competing you know so
drinking but you can't do all that you
know Jiu-Jitsu slowed my drinking down
big time like big time like when I went
from just being in a platoon I wasn't
doing Jiu-Jitsu cuz then what are you
doing on the weekends like you we'd go
to workout on the weekends but we go to
workout at like 10: in the morning so
you drink all night party whatever get
home the bars Clos at 2 o'clock in the
morning in California you know whatever
maybe you takes you till 3:00 you fall
asleep you still you know yeah wake up
at 6 hours later it's 9:00 go work out
you're totally in the game you're
totally in the parameters of the job and
of the life that you want to be living
now when you throw Jiu-Jitsu in there
and by the way you can go you don't have
to wrestle a pull-up bar you don't have
to wrestle the deadlift that thing
doesn't fight you back yeah so if you're
not giving it your all it doesn't know
no it doesn't right you know what I mean
like if you you couldn't get you know
your six rep your sixth rep it doesn't
care you just did five and it you don't
have to pay anybody for that yes sir but
on the mat of Justice there will be
justice justice is served oh yeah and if
you're competing that matters you know
where like if you're like okay I'm going
to go to training and you're competing
or whatever you got a tournament that
month that week whatever and you go
train and you have a bad day of training
that is like oh my gosh like freaking
should I be competing I'm not that good
or what you know like just dayto day
that's kind of like that constant
evaluation of your skill
so yeah if you're H over and you have
like multiple bad days of train that
gets in the way of your goals and it's
really obvious so did you had you cut
back on drinking during your Jiu-Jitsu
years um now that I think of it yeah but
it wasn't like a thing where I'd be like
okay it's just like hey if I if I can't
really drink then I don't drink you know
kind of a thing it wasn't like oh I
really need to cut back it wasn't that
it was like ijit I got jits tomorrow I'm
not going out tonight right I don't
consider drinking you know drinking is
like I have to consider actively you
know that I'm like oh yeah I can drink t
kind of a thing okay so you get injured
yes and now you can't train can't train
and this is when you're starting to get
creative for lack of a better where
you're making videos this is kind of the
beginning of your video career is I
think one that injury kind of opened up
that you know where cuz I can't go train
I can't lift really I mean even when I'm
lifting it's like you you don't have
many fitness goals you're trying to
achieve when you're injured like that so
you're just trying to maintain trying to
do rehab and stuff like that so in the
meantime what are you going to do kind
of a thing and yeah was always into that
creative stuff you know so yeah I picked
up a a camera whatever and started that
the reason I bring that up is because I
know that you have told me and you used
to tell me this even when you were
drinking you'd be
like explaining that you would kind of
get uh pleasure out of sitting there
making a video and drinking your what
did you used to drink vodka and soda
water or something yeah well at that
time I think it was vodka and grapefruit
juice okay so you're drinking vodka and
grapefruit juice yes and but you would
just drink that's what you do you sit in
the computer and you work on your videos
all night all night long yeah staying up
late well here's the thing sometimes you
used to come to record the podcast m in
the morning and you'd been up all night
well or a lot of the night yes oh yeah a
lot of the night pretty much all yeah
all night well if you remember fast for
a little bit the first few podcasts I
would drink while we're doing the
podcast that's insane dud and that was
just like like the first drink of the
night but yeah here's what it is though
why did you drink while we were
recording the podcast I didn't even know
you were drinking yeah it was just it
looked like a cup of water cuz no one
has a big cup like that of just full
of I don't know it is so you were
drinking that's inter I'm going to go
have to go back and listen to those and
see what drunk Echo but you weren't
really drunk nope you were just buzzing
after that one drink it's like you don't
really feel it till the end of it anyway
so it does it that was not a it didn't
really change me at all even when I
stopped drinking I didn't feel any
difference at all but um no and here's
the thing here's and I I'm going to say
this part because it's a trap because
this is part of the Trap
where because you know it's like an
addiction right so there's good
addictions and bad addictions and of
course both are kind of debatable on
certain levels or whatever but I got
addicted to the learning process of all
this video and CGI and all this stuff
because at that time that was the
beginning of the resource flood you know
like on YouTube and stuff you can learn
anything on YouTube like right now you
can learn pretty much anything on
YouTube you can literally learn how to
be a lawyer on YouTube right now um but
back then it was like that was the
beginning of all that and a big part of
it was video stuff and video related
stuff yeah and it's of course for videos
to learn there's going to be a lot of
videos to learn about videos to learn
because the people that know how to make
videos are making videos to learn
because they make videos exactly exactly
right so consider the little like trap I
kind of fell in cuz I was got addicted
to that as well that's all I wanted to
do what do you mean addicted like that's
all I wanted to do is like learn how to
do this next effect or this next type of
how many hours would you spend doing
that like 8 to 10 hours a day just
straight yes straight so a lot so like
during the day it wasn't as fun but
during the day and I'd try to get a
workout in of some sort Sarah would be
like come on like hey we want to eat
dinner and you'd be like I can't I'll be
down just eat without me type thing yes
yes not that specifically but yes though
I'm not doing that I'm not doing a bunch
of other things cuz I'm just going to be
Dorking out over here correct that is
correct yeah I mean we didn't have kids
till like later so it was just me and
her but um yeah oh yeah fully like I
wasn't going places even if I would go
places I would be like thinking about
yeah fully I was addicted to that but
then at the drinking now I was really
addicted to the process you know because
you're you get to it makes it like more
fun way more fun oh yeah so um but like
I said like that there's external things
that can make the addiction to the
drinking way more powerful like if
you're addicted to like going out
looking for chicks or like you know the
the other thing that you're into if it
involves drinking like it makes it like
double double addictive kind of a thing
just so happens mine was a constructive
thing but which ended up being a little
double-edged sword because now I can
rationalize it more you know yeah you
used to rationalize you used to
rationalize some videos and some ideas
that were just dumb oh yeah that was
part of it and we had many com ation
about that where you would basically say
you'd have an idea when you were 2:00 in
the morning and you were kind of drunk
and you'd spend three hours working
on yeah like something that just was
yeah that you shouldn't be working on
yeah in the next day oh yeah you know
how many like so we'd laugh about um
started videos started videos started
companies so I buy like five URLs like
xyz.com and the next day I'm like I
teaches CGI graphics.com oh trust me
that's a way better idea than the most
of them that I had but yeah you know
yeah that was that was the process right
there okay so we started this podcast in
2015 believe it or not and I remember
for a while you kind of like backed off
I remember you you know you were saying
like dude you and you kind of backed off
of drinking for a bit yeah um and you
kind of went back to maybe the normal
like all weekends whatever having a pool
party whatever something like this yeah
fully and a lot of that is because I had
kids so when you have kids or whatever
you make those adjustments but it's
weird because I'm not competing in
Jiu-Jitsu anymore and you know Fitness
is kind of like e you know like I don't
care that much about it even though I
did care about it it was still part of
the whole gig but I didn't care as much
because the career part of my life was
like um was improving you know and was
kind of establishing itself before the
podcast so as long as I could get the
work done as long as I could get a
workout in and as long as I wasn't um
failing as a parent the rest of the you
know is I fit in the drinking and just
so happens you can make a lot of
adjustments you know with these things
especially when you run your own
schedule so you can go okay I'm going to
drink and then okay you know kind of and
kind of battle through everything else
and still kind of be able to be
successful in it you can pull that off
so yes I wasn't getting like it wasn't
super heavy but basically I was
maintaining for sure but I'd go in and
out though like I would quit for like a
month you know that kind that guy which
is when you quit for a month why would
you quit for a month would you be like
dude I'm doing this too much and I'm not
getting stuff done you just sort of it's
a feeling that comes you know so was it
full like addict mode when you're like
dude I just really want to have a drink
right now or you say you know what I can
quit anytime see I just quit for a month
it's no big deal I'm good that was it
that was it yeah exactly right I never
felt like every once in a while when I'd
wake up like actually in The Hungover
realm where I drank kind of too much and
I'm physically feeling not that good
then I'd be like man I really need to
stop but then if it wasn't that I was
like because I proed to myself every
single day that I can power through the
day even if I'm a little bit dragging
you know it was that kind of scenario
and then what happened um like Co
basically Co now we're in lockdown
allegedly and look you your and I
lockdown was not like a normal person
lockdown I think we were kind of doing
what we were
doing uh but it did mean the kids are at
home it didn't mean there's no travel at
all yep you know I meu you you and I
traveled uh people were doing Jiu-Jitsu
in very small
groups and it was easy to not do
Jiu-Jitsu because well you could be like
well I don't know or whatever MH
so you started drinking more yeah in
lockdown yes sir so and here I think
this is important because I think a lot
of people are kind of in this Zone as
well
where coid lockdown yes I got to the
point where I could get good workouts in
and still drink every single day day and
a lot too but I could still get like PR
workouts in like good workouts in and
that's because you didn't really have
much else to do so you could like
literally lay in bed and more l oh yeah
I'm not going to work out until 6 o00
tonight and be all good to go exactly
exactly right but drink a bunch of water
you know some Gatorade like freaking you
know walk around a little bit do some
work you know I'm just sitting down in
front of the computer you know hanging
with my kids like kind of playing around
go outside throw the ball you know a
little bit you know like that kind it
wasn't like have to go to this work and
make all these decision really function
like cognitively you know it wasn't that
you basically used your day to recover
yes yep exactly exactly right and you
know it kind of helped that I had a real
tolerant wife or have a real tolerant
wife so she would just be like oh well
you were up late working cuz technically
I was so it's like yeah he just his his
though you were making a CGI video of a
freaking yeah the too Fair
chicken but but like I said it was kind
of like my work was delivering you know
where it there was no metric that you
could say hey you're failing at work in
fact it was the opposite it was like oh
yeah you're you know things are growing
yeah cuz now we had the podcast had the
podcast we're developing new things and
they were landing and you know it was
like like I said there was no metric to
say that that I was regressing you know
in in life all all arrows were pointed
in a positive direction we'll say most
yeah sure most arrows yeah so you can
kind of tolerate it you know so were
there any hints in there where you were
starting to think
like maybe I should not be drinking so
much no there was not not not noticeably
like given I don't know maybe like a a
general standard you know where like I
said like bro I don't go out and party I
don't go out and get into fights I don't
do illegal stuff I don't go to I'm not
going to jail I never had a DI nothing
like that so no I don't abuse anyone I
don't even get angry or nothing like
like that I get even more social when I
drink you know around people and I
wasn't really drinking around people
that much you know so I was like
freaking whatever yeah no nothing
tangible we'll say that I mean you could
go look into your brain and be like hey
am I reaching my potential or whatever
then yeah but that's different it's it's
funny how we can take our potential and
just say whatever about it I know you
know what I mean it's like you can take
your potential or
whatever as if that's not a an awesome
thing to go after as if your potential
as a human being is just a whatever it's
true it's a sad a sad State of
Affairs uh at a certain point though I
know some things kind of happened that
that you did think about like you had
some snowboard trip you went on with uh
with Cairo where what happened with that
yeah so it was the I think throughout
the drinking process there was something
in my head saying like this isn't good
like literally this is bad I don't we
we're not at the maturity level yet to
admit exactly why but we know it's there
lingering you know and you're saying you
me in myself in my own brain so I would
do these little tactics where I'd be
like hey freaking I'd pour my drinks out
like for the night you know I'd pour
them out like beforehand be like okay
there's like you know I know how much
vodka goes in one big drink so I'd pour
them out so I'm like okay I got four
drinks tonight or five drinks tonight or
whatever and then I'd take the bottle
and I'd be like Sarah freaking put this
hide this somewhere you know so I don't
cuz you after a few drinks that plan
goes right out the window you just want
that other one cuz you want the fun to
keep going so I knew that and so I got
to down to the system right and
sometimes it wouldn't work because
before the night would end for some I
don't know for whatever reason I'd go
like I don't know go in the bathroom or
something and I'd see oh that's where
she hid the bottle so I'd know it you
know like that I it was it was real
messed up it like behind the scenes
there was that says red that's like a
big giant red danger flag to me if I'm
if I'm asking my wife to hide the liquor
from me so that I can't drink it later
when I'm a little bit drunk yes yeah but
you didn't you didn't you actually
registered that as if you were squared
away good system exactly right it wasn't
perfect because i' defeat the system
sometimes but the point there isn't like
you know whether I felt good or bad
about it or nothing like that it was
more that it was obvious that something
was wrong that I was fighting against
even though like I felt or I could
rationalize to myself that it was
working it was obvious that something
like was wrong and it and I could feel
it you know so what happened with the
snowboard trip um you know one of these
moments of clarity I'm
like I realized I was one of these
people who had all these like for lack
of better term dreams and aspirations
and plans and one day I want to do this
and I'd really like to get into this
every time I see someone snowboarding
for example I'd be like oh man I've
always wanted to snowboard like for
years and years I grew up on quiet
there's no snow on kaai by the way so
I'm like oh man I would really love to
do that then I'm like wait a second I
could totally do that that like tomorrow
right you know like at this moment but
then why don't I and it never really
happened then one time just it was just
one of those happen stance moments of
clarity that I'd be like no like it
I'm I'm going to make the plan tell
Sarah and you know Sarah grew up in the
snow and she loves that kind of stuff
and she was like saying so anyway I made
the plan I was like hey let's go
snowboarding right here and Sarah signed
right on cuz she grew up in the still
she loves it she was freaking super
happy she was even saying freaking I've
been waiting for you to get out of your
routine to start doing more stuff like
this or whatever I was like okay cool
and then we did it and we went up there
it was like the best man everyone
freaking loved it I freaking I loved it
I liked it even better than I thought I
would so it's like one of those things
and it was just yet another hint that
bro there's a world out here that like
is like Limitless that you can things
you can do things you can learn things
you can you know have the potential of
like embracing and succeeding in you
know on all these different levels and
it's all out there waiting but that
drinking which that it always came back
down to the drinking cuz I can work all
you know I can work a lot and still do
that stuff cuz I'll have the energy to
do it but drinking you spend the just
like I said you spend the whole day
recovering essentially so you're like if
you're not in the mood to do something
bro that feeling goes way up way up when
you're dragging from drinking and for
you that was even true with that Jujitsu
yeah it was like a struggle to go you
know where I'd be dragging myself to and
the other day you came and you were
telling me afterwards like bro JSU is so
fun so fun oh yeah like it's like you
know back in the day where I think we're
all kind of like this who've been into
Jiu-Jitsu for a long time back in the
day like you couldn't wait to go to
Jiu-Jitsu even like when you when you
wake up like in my case I'd wake up in
the morning and I'd be like how
long is it till I get to go to jiujitsu
just can't wait everything about is fun
doesn't matter if you get tapped or
don't tap doesn't matter nothing matters
it's just like just being there and
doing it it was fun everything from the
moment you step so I'd always think
think about it but bro when you're
dragging bro that's kind of the last
thing I want to do right now is go get
freaking choked by Joo and stuff and
freaking get claustrophobia cuz he won't
let me up so then the window starts to
close and you're like well I woke up a
little bit late and I gotta you know I
do want to do this and I got to take out
the garbage and plus I was supposed to
you know what probably not the best day
for me to go oh yeah fully and it's
habitually that would happen so much
that after a while I kind of like forgot
about it in this sense where you forget
about Jiu-Jitsu because it's just not in
the schedule and then every once it'll
click oh wait I could go to Jiu-Jitsu
right now then I'd like drag myself and
go so I'd hardly ever go I'd go like
once a week once every two three weeks
you know like that kind there was a
competition of jiujitsu this weekend
yeah hell yeah world league and yeah
world league good tournaments uh run
super smooth all good well my daughter
competed and she she was competing she
did ghe and no ghee and she was
competing with the ghee and she's in
like a tough match you know these are
you know it's tough
matches and I see you know some
transition and I look at her and she's
smiling like like like not a huge like
over the toop smile but just like a
smile as if she's like watching you know
the office or just like a nice little
smile like she's just having a good time
in the middle of a little bit of a you
know a hardcore match you know people TR
people are trying to break your arm
people are trying to choke you and like
she like Maneuvers around she's getting
the girls back and like I look at her
face and she's smiling like this like a
I'm so happy and I was like yeah that's
the Jiu-Jitsu right there oh yeah it is
and I zoomed in cuz I was videoing I
zoomed in I try I think I tried I
haven't reviewed the tape yet but I
think I caught like she's putting a
choke on someone and she's smiling just
to herself you know I mean she wasn't
looking around she's just herself in her
own world that moment in time there was
peace and happiness in her world that's
real and that's a real thing oh yeah and
bro that's like one of the things
too that what drinking in this case like
what drinking just robs from you cuz
there's that like that idea that little
thing that smile that freaking happiness
you know you'd be surprised how many
things in life like that that exists in
and bro I'm telling you you'll miss I
don't know I did I totally would miss a
bunch of that stuff you know cuz I'm
like focusing on recovering and like you
know you're dragging you're not in the
mood for anything so things that are
supposed to give you the in Eternal
smile aren't doing it not doing it not
doing it and you get used to it so it's
like a kind of a sad State of Affairs
you know so now you're just not smiling
very as much not as much at all what
about what about did you lose the let's
say like you're making videos and you're
still into that and you did you lose any
of that no you still like that you still
got an internal smile yeah yes sir did
you feel like the cuz you know you'll
hear a rock and roll guy say like well
you know we wrote this song we were high
we were drunk that's kind of like helped
us make this wild stuff I heard Joe
Rogan will say like you know these dudes
were high as hell you know uh did you do
how do you feel about your
creativity with alcohol yeah I would say
that that's a real thing in my
experience I felt like that was a real
thing for sure cuz
like to to think back and analyze it it
was like from an idea standpoint all my
idea you know and this goes for Everyone
by the way for the most part where when
you drink all your ideas seem good not
just the good ones that's what I
remember you telling me is like you tell
me like when you're drinking you think
all your ideas are good which is which
is not good because then you don't
prioritize an execute you don't
prioritize you just think you just had
19 good ideas last night oh yeah and
they're all stupid well 18 of them are
dumb well think about it this makes
sense and it's true because
when I video who who cares about making
videos or making creative stuff just say
in life when you go out drinking all
ideas are good bro let's all take off
our clothes go to the freaking PE pier
in PB and jump off in the middle of the
night that seems like a good idea when
you're drinking and I know this cuz
that's literally what I did with my this
is a long time ago but this this is like
one of the things you do and then when
you think back you're like bro that was
a wasn't a good idea get arrested
literally in the moment it seems like a
good idea bro let's get into a fight
with that guy I don't like how he looks
I don't like how he like looked at me I
don't know if he looked at me or not but
I just don't like it let's get a fight
that seems like a good idea and then
you'll just execute you know it's like
that's everybody everyone thinks an idea
most ideas seem good but it can kind of
help you when you're formulating
creative ideas so you're just like
everything is included so you're just
like doing it and following through and
it's part of the learning process as
well so it's like there was always a big
payoff for me for that so it would help
me I think I mean results wise I don't I
don't know but process wise it did yeah
it made work way more fun so I guess
there's something that Carrie said to
you mhm that left an impact what did K
dog say to you yeah we were at Sushi and
I was drinking sakei too by the way and
it still made an impact where he was
explaining to me one of the car doesn't
drink anymore yeah at all yep so and I
was asking well yeah you know why not or
whatever and I wasn't trying to get him
to drink at all I was just wondering
like what's that you know what's the
process keep in mind like nowadays too
we it's we slowly hear more and more
people kind of start saying like hey
yeah I haven't drank for like two years
it was just getting in the way you know
and even you what you would say but I
just thought you were just different but
even you saying something very specific
which really landed on me after I
stopped drinking was you just said
simply drinking doesn't help you that's
all you said so I was like oh damn but
before that Carrie said oh well he's
like in a nutshell the reason I quit
drinking is because on one hand if I
drink my life goes to every single
time and on this on this hand when I
don't drink my life literally gets
better and better and better and doesn't
stop and I was like oh damn that's like
a good
even if that's not factually true for
anyone like that's literally how it
works most of the time yeah I
mean it'd be hard pressed to find
someone that their life gets better when
they're drinking and gets worse when
they're sober exactly right maybe you
could take some kind of a short-term
tactical view that like oh I'm going to
have more fun at this party but if you
want to talk about yeah at your life
broads broads broadly speaking mhm
there's no one that's on the list of
like my life is better when I'm drinking
alcohol yeah or ever since I picked up
drinking more it my life has improved
you know by so much you so he says that
to you while you're drinking yeah
drinking yep while you're kicking back
Saki and Sushi yeah yeah and it was it
was a fun time and that that did add
like another little inkling of an
ingredient to be like cuz like I said
like I wasn't 100% okay with it but
that's you know I did I wasn't enough I
wasn't not okay enough with it to
actually stop so but that added like
another little thing that really stuck
with me that pushed nudged me in the
direction of like okay at some point
this is going to have to stop so at what
point did you reach the The Tipping
Point what was it or what what were the
final kind of like items it was weird it
was almost like a um like a super
anticlimactic ending to a movie or
something like that it wasn't like oh
yeah you know how like some people
they'll be like and this is what I do
too I'd be like yeah I'm going to stop
drinking on Monday and it's like a
Friday you know so I'm going to have one
last you know deal and then on Monday
it'll happen then maybe it works maybe
it doesn't and it for sure doesn't stick
right but mine was like it was like
three or four days before camp and the
Jiu-Jitsu Camp Jiu-Jitsu Camp yeah and
you know I for whatever reason just
didn't drink before like a few days
before that just by half inance and then
I went to camp and then I think in Camp
like
things gel because you're just in the
mountains and a lot of times like we're
just you just by yourself in the cabin
you know and so like all the information
and you know that that's kind of rolling
around in your life kind of like gels in
your brain I think I think that was it
that's
it and you kind of do the math and you
kind of like search your feelings and
all this stuff and you kind of realize
wait a second drinking even short term
has not been really serving me in a way
and then if I could ever find it in
myself to like not drink for a week it's
like why I feel so much better just in
in general and like you kind of consider
sure I did some cool things like outside
of my normal routine and you know
developed cool traditions and you know
you know snowboarding was just one of
them and that is cool but imagine how
many other things could like materialize
if I just freaking finally just turn my
back on drinking you know what about
that incident that we had um we had an
incident
at camp with you me
my daughter
Hannah uh couple other people and there
was a dude at camp and we all just
sitting around for Mid rfts or whatever
like the the the post evening Jiu-Jitsu
session oh yeah they bring out food and
you can kind of go get you know make a
make a sandwich grab a Mulk was kind of
the deal yeah so we're all in there
doing that and you're kind of tired you
know but you just got done training but
you're not you know you going to go get
some food you don't want to go catabolic
no so when there eating
and uh they made announcement like hey
if you guys want some beer there's some
beer in there you know Etc and not all I
mean we were all just got done training
we're not feeling like drinking and
there was a dude at the table with us
like kind of an older dude probably like
a little bit older than me and he stands
up and like walks over the cooler well
before that that guy we were talking
with him beforehand and he's a
successful dude like Works in I think
Silicon Valley or something like that
started some company was an or something
like that like yeah like a successful
dude that's you know at Camp doing
Jiu-Jitsu on the path I mean it's like
all good right Y and then he we know we
we don't think anything of it you know
there's like an announcement hey there's
beer in the coolage if you guys want to
grab a beer cool he kind of just hears
that and I don't think anything of it
yeah he stands up goes over grabs a beer
you know all good comes back and I
remember he he kind of like put the beer
on the table and he reached to open it
and he goes I haven't had a drink in 20
years and I look at him and I just go
hey were you an
alcoholic and he got a look on his face
like he just got busted kind of yeah and
also saved yeah at the same time that's
a good way to put it and he
goes yeah I was and I was like what what
the are you doing bro I was like
give give me that and I took it
away from him and I was like go get a
milk and like you ain't drinking this is
horrible boom so he was kind of like
like I said he looked like he got busted
then he looked like he got saved and he
walked over and he grabbed the
MK and I remember I was uh walking back
with with my
daughter and cuz then you know we all
sat there for a little while and at the
you know when we left I was like hey bro
you know this is do not drink like do
not come to this freaking camp and
derail your life and he's like no I'm
sorry I don't know what I was thinking I
don't know what happened he was a little
bit like he almost got possessed in that
moment the weird thing was it wasn't
like the possession was random because I
could understand if you know we were all
like hooting and hollering and listening
to freaking Brazilian dance music or
whatever and we're all in there you know
pumping our fists in the air and and
having drinks but we weren't we're
sitting around literally talking about
jiujitsu getting ready to go to bed so
it was weird that he got caught up in
that
moment so I'm driving back or driving I
think I was driving one those little
golf CS back with my daughter and she
just looked at me and she said there's
nothing good about alcohol is there and
I said no there's not it's
horrible uh the good news is I talked to
him like following like there was three
days left at Camp every day I talked to
him you know and I just said hey man how
are you doing he's like dude I don't
know what happened I'm totally good to
go like that was weird I hadn't even had
it what this is the thing that I
remember he goes
he goes I remember he goes when I picked
up that beer we I got to the table he
goes I put my f my fingernail got
underneath the whatever that thing's
called yeah the opener he said my finger
got underneath that opener and I started
to feel like oh it's
back cuz you can imagine like a junkie
like how how that feeling like when you
get that you're like oh it's almost here
it's almost here and he got that feeling
he remembered that feeling for 20 years
got his fingernail and he's like oh I
get to go back I get to have it and then
boom no the are you doing and he
was danger close yeah danger close from
going down God knows what happens that
was a incredible moment to see because
you can see how two things number one
you can see how easy it is MHM and
number two you can see how much
impactful it is to have someone around
you that's going to be like looking out
for you a little bit yeah or for someone
to step in and help help you get through
tough situations yeah so that to me was
a was a was definitely a good Learning
lesson me too uh to be watching out for
other people and also the level after 20
years you can get sucked back in and
think you're okay and think it's going
to be all good it's not yeah it's not
it's not going to be okay it's not going
to be good it's not going to bring you
anything no sure that was um that
impacted me too by the way cuz I wasn't
I didn't really like make any kind of
decision especially at that point where
it I was just doing camp like I don't
really drink in Camp I think I mean
maybe a few years ago I had like a you
know how they have wine sometimes I like
had a drink I don't drink in Camp for
whatever reason um and
then the uh experiencing that right
there was like really thinking back it
was like a good uh situation where I was
detached from it and I could see the two
you know the two sides of It kind of
playings out right and then you're you
were like the you know the the good guy
and and he was like the victim and the
alcohol was kind of like the bad guy the
little devil you know and you were there
you know the little fight just ensued
right in front of my face and this guy
bro he almost went down straight up cuz
it's not like you saw the whole thing
happening we didn't know anything I
didn't know anything actually that's
what someone someone else that was at
the table with us said to me like I
never would have asked that me I said
that okay it was you yeah you're like I
never would ask that because to me if
someone if someone some stopped drinking
there's a good chance they were an
alcoholic and if they say I haven't
drank for 20 years that's a that's like
letting you know there there's an issue
yeah and you know I when I stopped
drinking I stopped drinking kind of like
you like I just kind of stopped drinking
yeah um I didn't have any reason to
drink anymore I just so it wasn't like
an epiphany moment for me that was like
I didn't wake up you know in the
freaking gutter with my wallet gone and
my wife left me and my kids whatever no
I I just retired from the Navy oh I'm
out of the Navy like oh yeah I used to
drink with those guys those guys aren't
really here anymore uh oh I saw one of
them last weekend oh cool we had a drink
but I still got to go home I got work to
do I got this I got that and then just
eventually over a pretty short period of
time I was like yeah this is stupid yeah
um I don't need to be doing this and
then that was
that so you had these things so you get
to Camp you don't drink at Camp did you
decide at Camp you know what I'm done
was that at Camp yeah I think so but it
was like a light it wasn't like a you
know draw the line in the sand kind of a
decision it was just like bro I think I
think I'm kind of done and it's got you
know how you can kind of have these
little what scares me about that is
there's a lot of people the description
that you just gave and the description
that I just gave I don't think that's
normal I think if you have a problem
with alcohol you have to draw a line in
the sand that's what I think I actually
don't think I have a problem with
alcohol matter of fact I know I don't
like I I have no desire to drink when I
stopped drinking I had no desire to
drink so I can't say that I would have a
problem but I think in I think people
that have a problem they have to draw
line and sand and I know this cuz I've
known alcoholics yeah me too the one
beer oh just know I'm just going to have
a few tonight that's not a thing it's
not a thing if you're an alcoholic it's
not at
all yeah and I do believe that
everything is a
spectrum but I I think
that being in alcoholic this is what it
seems like that that that's a spectrum
as well but the really the the way that
to ensure that it's going to be
effective that you can win the fight
against that kind of stuff is to draw
the line in the sand for sure that as
far as like
reliably win that's that's the way to do
it 100% what's weird is if you're
listening to this right now and you're
thinking like
well I don't really think I would need
to quit drinking because I don't think I
have a problem with it so therefore I
I'll just keep drinking it's sort of
like that's just indicated to you that
you actually really want to keep
drinking you probably have a problem
yeah if you're like yeah you know what I
don't I I don't think I should drink
either you probably don't have a real
problem and you stop yeah if you're
listening it's like yeah well I don't
really wouldn't need to draw a line this
if you're making if you're already
making excuses hearing this and by the
way if I sound like I'm trying to get
you not to drink if you're listening to
this I am I don't want you to drink I
know it doesn't help you you mhm I know
it only will hurt you I know it brings
no benefit in your life I know it hurts
your health it hurts your mindset it
hurts your workout tomorrow it hurts
your interaction with your family it
just doesn't do anything good for you
doesn't help as I said to you corre a
few years ago drinking does not help you
in any
way so I'm recommending Line in the
Sand yep I'm going to stop drinking
right when right now if you have to give
yourself this weekend that's definitely
telling you that you should stop right
now yeah that's right now that is sorted
itself out that method it sorted itself
out to be a failure yeah and I've always
threatened to do like a a podcast on the
straight edge I think we might have done
an underground a little bit on straight
edge but just the straight edge scene
when I was growing up and what that was
like the there's a a whole genre of
Hardcore music that's all straight edged
Don't drink don't smoke don't do drugs
yeah and it look it it spun off into all
kinds of wild directions uh but the the
core of it very positive in my opinion
definitely kept me out of that kind of
stuff when I was younger and I know it's
kept a lot of kids and brought a lot of
people onto the more positive thing side
of things but it's what it's a small
small genre most music is telling you to
drink telling you to party oh yeah
that's what most music is doing it's
terrible yep you do notice a lot of that
stuff too like how much and this sounds
like obvious and there nothing new but
like how much alcohol is part of like
our culture and even the good parts of
our culture right so you you know we
just traveled recently so I'm looking at
all the cool advertisements on the
electric Billboards and like all this
stuff and one of them is like oh finally
get a break you know get away whatever
go to this hotel right and they show all
the cool fun family stuff at this hotel
and the kids running around like real
wholesome stuff kind of like oh man that
seems kind of nice and a few of the
clips are like you know the parents
cheersing their wine and their like uh
tropical drinks and they didn't say hey
there's alcohol in here but it's like
obviously alcohol like that's what
they're selling you know yeah I mean the
wine was obviously alcohol too but um
but it's like just and it's just it
that's just how that's just part of it
you know it's not like a big deal and
they're not saying hey wink wink you can
if you really want to you can have some
of this stuff if you really want to go
hard they're not saying that they're
saying hey this is part of the family
wholesome uh refreshing recuperative
experience of our awesome Hotel yeah
like oh yeah by the way alcohol too by
the way in that one so hell yeah come
get it you know kind of a thing and it
and to be honest it seemed kind of nice
the little ad was like oh that looks
kind of nice but I was like huh
interesting they slit it in there slit
it right right in there all right so you
quit drinking what do you notice when
you quit drinking like what how long did
it take you to start feeling the effects
of like I'm not drinking anymore now I'm
not drinking it's been this many days it
well immediately So and I've always
known this and ask like Greg Jane right
Greg McIntyre um I always talk to him
about drinking even when I was drinking
we just talk about it the effects or
what if I go like one day without
drinking the next day not feeling that
drag bro I feel like Superman I was like
bro no wonder guys can work so hard they
feel like freaking they have endless
energy you know cuz I'm so used to
dragging you know um and but for
whatever reason it just didn't you know
take hold or whatever um but so of
course I feel that like you just have
and you're not dragging and when you're
used to dragging like for just literally
like a decade of dragging pretty much
every day as the normal and now you're
not dragging you're like holy cow it's
like you shed like a big ball in chain
it's just cut loose you know I was going
to say you've been wearing a weight vest
20 lb weight vest for the last freaking
10 years mentally that's literally what
it feels like and then it's weird
because that feeling just gets stronger
and stronger as like the weeks go on so
you're like holy cow like I didn't know
like it was weird like I
always had this happen where I'd be
dragging and then and if you drink it
enough I given the kind of the research
or whatever I've done it's like it kind
of get puts you into a literal
depression because you're like your
chemical balance or whatever kind of
gets imbalanced in that way because it's
like this cycle and all this stuff so
I'd feel that not super strong but I'd
feel it every once in a while where I'd
be like what is this dumb like life is
kind of like pointless in a way not it's
not suicidal nothing like this but it's
just kind of like all right you work and
you do this and it's like who I mean but
why does that even matter you know you
go down this weird spiral it's not super
powerful but it's there and I'm like
yeah I don't know whatever all right
cool whatever and then I go crack open a
drink no no no not at all I'd go workout
and I do a hard workout cuz like I said
I got into a point to the point where I
could totally do a sick workout being
hung over I go do a workout and after
maybe the first two three like hard sets
boom this Rush of like oh my gosh life
has so much more meaning now and I don't
know why I know it's not cuz I worked
out and life is freaking you know life
is lifting I'm not saying that but it
was just this more like a little bit and
it kind of is but it was just more of a
feeling you know and I was like Fu
there's some chemical going on in
my head that that is causing to feel
like this and this working out hard like
this is kind of helping me balance it
out so that feeling that the workout at
that moment cuz it's happened a few
times that feeling just like is like
constantly there Norm yeah so it's like
every once in a while I'll be doing some
normal everyday and then I'll be
like why am I having so like why am I
enjoying this so much right now and then
usually I'll say cuz Sarah knows that I
stopped drinking or you even a lot of
times I'll be like like how I said isn't
jiu-jitsu just so freaking awesome or
whatever like that when I'm having those
feelings like I'll express it to anyone
around who who can appreciate it I'll be
like broh you know how freaking cool it
is to not drink or what you know how
I'll say that sometimes is because of
that reason cuz you start like
appreciating everything more and I did
anyway um and and as the weeks kind of
went on it just got more powerful more
and more powerful you know so that that
was it that was the experience so now
all these ideas that you're like I need
to do more of this or I need to start
this or whatever you're just freak hey
it's time let's do it let's start it and
then you just do you know you follow
through with way more
stuff so I'd say yeah that's that's the
impact for sure so you did
you did you tell Sarah your wife did you
say hey I quit drinking um or did you
like she said oh do you want to me to
make you a drink and you're like no I'm
good and then the next day she said do
you want me to make you a drink he said
no I'm good and I think I I don't really
need it you know like I I didn't like
tell her and I'm trying to remember cuz
again it wasn't like this big deal I was
just cuz and let's face it like I've
probably said it I think I'm done with
drinking a bunch of times before so you
felt like maybe you didn't need to say
it again 50th time exactly right that's
all I would have felt pointless yes to
say it like hey I'm but I did end up
saying it I said but I said it hey I
think I'm kind of done with drinking it
just said that and she was like yeah me
too you know she'll say that so what she
just got on board well I think in the
moment she thought okay we're going to
try this again you know kind of a thing
and then um and then I didn't drink and
she was like after a few days she was
like oh shoot I'm I think I'm with you
you know kind of a thing and then she
now she's feeling good yeah yeah she you
know I think most of us are like this
where it's like oh that's what
we're doing okay I can sign on to that
you know like unless it's like some bad
decision you know so it was kind of that
going on and then yeah so that was that
was it did did you take the alcohol out
of your house I didn't I didn't no do
you feel like Temptation no so no what's
your favorite alcoholic beverage vodka
soda with lemon vodka soda with lemon
and like do you have
that do you have that in your house
right now um I I don't I don't know I
don't know do you have any desire where
you're kind of like feeling like it oh
no so I'm trying to think have I ever
had that since every once in a while
here's it's this is weird anytime I hear
like an old song that I used to like a
lot because really when I really analyze
my feelings it's more like um the
benefit that alcohol did bring in the
short term was like I could feel more
like I could feel like all the feeling
like you know if you really get into a
certain song you know the feeling it was
like oh man if I had a beer to help
enjoy this it was more that so I'll be
like oh man if I had to like to really
immerse myself in the feeling but it
it's such a fleeting feeling you know
it's like once the song ends you're like
freaking whatever that was a dumb
thought kind of a thing so it was that
uh I will say this though and and this
is kind of important too where it's
nothing new but it's this is really I am
convinced this is a massive massive deal
where okay so when I go out to Sushi I
always drink saki mhm so I went out to
Sushi a few times once with my son no
saki for probably the first time in a
long time it was just me and him though
he's seven no saki so I was like oh
freaking it was way better with him like
way better than than my memories of
going and drinking saki I don't think
I've ever gone with just him before but
nonetheless I remember thinking man this
is better I'm like talking to him more
way more into this now few weeks later I
went with my
cousin um and I had seen him for a while
or whatever and I went out to Sushi and
it was cool really cool to see him but
it was not fun it wasn't as fun as like
it seemed been drinking a little bit
yeah good to see you cuz yes exactly
right and I think it was
mainly because you know it's your cousin
no he doesn't drink at all either okay
well yeah so it was good overall of
course it was a great time catching up
with him all this stuff but put it this
way and it probably had a lot to do with
my expectation because him he's you know
he's a professional comedian you know so
I'm thinking festive festive party time
you see what I'm saying but it was L it
was a lot more mature that's what it was
it was a mature interaction you know
which was cool but I think it comparing
it to my expectation it was like oh
shoot it wasn't the party that I almost
I guess in a way expected you know so
there was that so what's the big deal
you said this is a big deal oh because
when you go in certain
environments like if put it this way he
doesn't drink and it was with his
girlfriend as well and and she said oh
yeah I drink but not really so it's not
like she's going to start drinking when
I just when we were talking about not
drinking so none of us were
drinking so if he were to in that moment
if he were to be like oh yeah like I
yeah I drink freaking let's get get some
saki come on like all good not in a
pressure way I'm just saying like if he
were to offered that up as an
option and I and I was like oh yeah
it I started drinking sake what I
wouldn't have been surprised at all
because of that you know thing and
there's all these rationalizations that
you can go through like in your head
wait if he' had said that you think you
would have been drinking yeah that night
yeah yeah even though you quit drinking
yeah because I I didn't it it's weird
cuz it doesn't feel like I like drew a
line in the s I just I just came to the
realization drinking doesn't help you
you know kind of a thing seems a little
bit sketchy yes it does yeah seems a
little bit seems like that might be a it
might be an indicator that A Line in the
Sand would be better that's why I think
a Line in the Sand is better a lot more
reliable so now hopefully after this
podcast comes out people will just be
like oh yeah eeko quit drinking and
hopefully they won't be like oh let's
see if we can get him to drink yeah
we'll put it this if someone tried to
get me to drink then now it's like
another thing now it's a challenge me
and you and bro I'm winning I I feel
like it anyway that's an additional I
put on that special song and I offer you
some sushi and Saki and then I start
vibing out the best way the best way to
do it is be a person who doesn't know
any better and want to drink some saki
with meh then yes I will you're giving
people the game plan yeah yeah but you
know yeah if you can pull it off
whatever now you can be suspect of
people that act like they don't really
know you and just act like they're
trying to have fun and actually just
offer you some
suit yeah it's going to be to on purpose
pull that off I don't know it doesn't
seem like it'd work but um but yeah
that's why I say it's a big deal because
you can go in an a certain specific
environment and relapse real easy
especially if you can justify it like
that you know yeah like the Alcoholic
Anonymous thing is like people places
and things yeah you can't see the people
you used to see mhm you can't go to the
places you used to go and you can't do
the things you used to do if they have
to do with alcohol so you can't go see
your old you know buddy Fred
who likes to get liquored up you can't
go to the bowling alley cuz that's where
I used to drink and get liquored
up so that's oh and then I can't Bowl
cuz that's the thing that I do or fish
or whatever thing I'm doing I'm drinking
so you know why that is the the the
thing what is it what would bowling be
people plac things so that's the thing
that I do okay so let's go places right
so if you're used to going bowling in my
case going to Sushi with friends and
freaking talking so a lot of timesit
yeah it's like it's like habit it's a
habitual thing but like there's more to
it it feels like there's it's there's
something a lot more compelling cuz
habit seems like something where you
should just snap your brain and get out
of the Habit like I feel like that's
kind of the thing even though I know
there's more to it routine routine habit
but almost on a level of necessity so
like if I go to sushi or if let's say I
go bowling and I'm like okay now when I
go bowling I don't drink beers now and I
go and now bowling is really boring now
because all that like Association kind
of works off each other you know to make
this experience now that one lacking
element provides this experience that's
not not as fun it's not as quot unquote
pleasurable because of all the you know
so now you're in that same experience
bowling and now it's super boring so now
you're kind of angry like hey man what
like I had this thing that was a
enjoyable experience part of my routine
my tradition my whatever you know my
whole thing and now I don't like it like
so you kind of rebel against that and
add that ingredient again you know it's
like that that idea is s it's it's uh
it's super strong you know so it's hard
to defeat unless you really kind of dig
deep and and analyze it for what it is
you were telling me that you feel like
you can control your brain now more yeah
it's true which is like mind control
from freaking uh discipline Freedom
feeli manual now you feel what the I
feel yep I do actually and that that
went through my mind so much where I'm
like freaking this is how Jaco does it
he just doesn't drink you know it's like
I know there's more to it than that I
know but the feeling is that night and
day where you know the idea of um hey
you want to do something right you want
to do something for yourself or with
yourself or um you know you have some
goal you have or whatever things it's
not nothing huge like freaking I want to
lose you know how easy or you know how
simple it is to lose weight if you want
to lose weight you know how simple it is
to work out every day like if you were
like hey your life like if you had like
some ter like terrorist person and was
like Hey I'm going to kill you if you
don't work out 5 days a week this week
I'm going to kill you the moment that
the it turns midnight and you haven't
worked out I'm going to kill you he's
right there and you can't kill him bro
you would easily do that it wouldn't be
a problem so it's like it's it's super
simple to do it you just essentially
find reasons not to right so excuses
exactly right excuses right so excuses
are powerful but they're only as
powerful as you allow them to be so if
you can if you say okay I'm going to you
know I'm going to set this goal
short-term medium-term whatever and then
you don't do it you can't control your
mind you for real can't control your
mind because somewhere along the line
you said yeah I said I'd do that but I'm
not going to do that you know kind of
thing it's like bro you can't control
your mind for some reason I
mean I don't know where the disconnect
is but for some somewhere you lost
control of your mind that's a crazy
thing to think about like we think about
the power of the human will and people
make all kinds of goals and they just
never do them just choose not to do just
like no I'm instead going to freaking
sit around and watch Netflix yeah that's
actually what they do oh yeah yep
exactly right that's very crazy so you
know how you you're whole and it's half
joke it's probably not even half joke
it's like probably like 1% joke the rest
truth even though it sounds like a joke
you know how you're like oh how is a
donut more powerful than your mind or
whatever you know like the whole school
that whole work into sugarcoated lies
like that thing so really think about
that in actual boots on the ground
freaking reality real life think about
that like I do not like let's say I
don't know let's say it's an aesthetic
thing right you like I don't like the
way I don't know my body looks or I
don't like my health my current health
health the most important thing probably
yeah if you lose your health you lose
what yeah the most important thing you
only get one body like you know that
whole thing really analyze it for what
it is so now this dut is literally a
step backwards now right and the donut
isn't a person who's like it's not a
manipulative creature BR it's just
existing it's literally just existing
like you can literally close your eyes
and it doesn't even you can't even see
it like it's it's not like you can't
really smell a donut much most of them
and here's the thing that doesn't matter
either BR the thing could you could
literally like throw it down the can and
it'd be done throw it in the Trap is
gone you know it's not a thing that
follows you around and forces that your
hand behind your back or you got to like
tap or nothing like that it's like just
existing yeah and you're like okay I'm
going to do this with my heal it's like
going it's like going out you know we
have the grappling dummy yeah which is
for those of you that don't know what
that is it's like a it's like a punching
bag with arms but just a stuffed
punching bag with arms yeah imagine you
walk out on the mats and you get tapped
by that
thing that's what happens when you eat a
donut literally it's like something that
beats you that has no no mind of its own
can't even move towards you it can't do
anything and yet you go out there and
you just trip over the grappling dummy
and break your arm I would I mean you're
you're absolutely right and it's almost
like not even an analogy it's almost
like literally that's what you're doing
because the grappling dummy like your
mind made it into a grappling dum dummy
it's just cotton and freaking leather
and and cloth like put together in a
certain your mind was like o that looks
like a person now that's a and it's over
there in the corner and you chose to
walk over there and you didn't trip over
it you walked and got into the triangle
choke of the you put his legs over you
put energy into putting his legs over
your head under your arm and then like
squee you squeezed it he didn't squeeze
that's just cotton cotton doesn't
squeeze nothing you squeezed it and then
tapped and be like man I just I just
didn't have the skill today you know
just had a bad day BR no you didn't you
had the skill you had everything and
then you chose to do it expended ener by
a freaking piece of cloth yep exactly
right the the same exact thing and
here's the thing it's not like you just
tapped out and whatever with a dut you
literally have taken a step backward
with in a very important one of the most
important things that you have in your
whole life and you took a step backwards
just cuz you couldn't control your mind
that's
why and you feel like you have more mind
control now that you're not drinking
100%
100% uh hey what about I know one of the
biggest things that you say you TI away
from the podcast in general is the
ability to see
the Strategic Vision the big picture the
long-term plan as opposed to the
short-term gratification tactical what
I'm doing right now today yeah do you
feel like the big picture the long-term
strategic plan has become more clear and
easier to navigate towards yes sir big
time actually I would even go one step
further and say it became clear because
before I realized it was there so like
moment to moment you're like okay you
can make the evaluation but you now I
feel like I can like actually see it for
what it is like this actual real
existing kind of
thing yeah I feel like I have way more
access to it
now
so you have this Focus you can control
your brain you understand the big
picture
um you go through life you'd heard you
you always hear people tell you that you
know alcohol is not good for you I told
you you know I mean I never was like
dude you shouldn't I don't think I ever
said to you you shouldn't drink no you
gave me more about getting a Coke
the first time you like a Coca soda
Coca-Cola yeah yeah more than you ever
did about anything drinking yeah well I
don't like that high fructose corn syrup
going into your you know into your gut
you're offended uh but you heard heard
that but you never really understood the
power of not drinking you know what I'm
saying like as many people said oh yeah
it's a waste it's poison it's all this
stuff you never said to yourself you
know what I mean for a long time for 10
years of drinking you never said to
yourself you know what this actually
more than 10 years probably 15 years of
drinking you never said to yourself my
life would be way better if I stopped
right now that you've stopped is it even
better than you thought it would be or
you had it would be it is on par and
keep in mind MH it's exactly how I put
it this way I never really actually
imagined it I just knew it as like kind
of like the answers to a test almost you
know like kind of like if someone were
to ask me
hey would your life be better or worse
without drinking I'd be like better
because I know that that's true I can't
feel it though I didn't feel you know
you don't know know it yeah how how much
better how does that look when I do this
how does that look I never really
thought real deep into that part of it I
I would I was just basically going
moment to moment you know like so if I
could pull it off you know one day one
week without drinking then I could feel
it you know but I didn't really like I
guess I failed to formulate any kind of
like structure or plan or or Vision into
the future you know I was like cool I I
did it and I know that's good for me you
know but now I can kind of cut loose and
whatever you know kind of thing it was
like a moment to moment kind of thing I
think once it kind of takes hold and
then you you recognize it for what it is
and then you kind of get exposed to in a
real way what you could be doing and
what your life could be and you're
exposed to it actually happening and
then you say okay I choose right now to
to pursue this and not pursue this and
go back to what freaking K Dog Carri
hton said where you just go binary go be
like okay hey I could either go this
this path and be like hey my life is
going to go to every single time
and in real life it doesn't go to
every single time level 10 it doesn't
but it might go level 0.1 yeah or more
0. five or one up yeah exactly right and
here's the thing it did whether it adds
up or not I mean it does add up yes oh
freak yeah obviously but it doesn't
matter you're choosing to go negative
per like per like event you're choosing
it as opposed to the other choice go
positive yeah so it's like okay so I
could either go here where my life goes
to every single time or I could go
here where my life improves every single
time and doesn't end so then you kind of
if you can kind of formulate that whole
structure in your head and be like I
choose this one right it it does become
a lot easier for
sure well I have noticed in the past few
months since camp that your productivity
is higher your attitude is better I mean
you never have like a bad attitude but
your attitude is better I mean even
coming to train yeah you know I used to
like laugh when you CH up to train I'd
be like oh you going to train today huh
now you're you're in there ready to go
yes sir you're you're uh I'd say
benefiting across the board what's crazy
to me is like what else is like that
yeah you know what I mean what else is
it is what about your phone like in in
the in the social media that you're
looking at or what about the food that
you're eating or what about like the
cold exposure like what little what
little things are out there Jiu-Jitsu a
lot of people don't know that that a
smile on your face right mhm a lot of
people don't know that kind of thing so
it is
definitely it is definitely and it's
it's interesting what's interesting
about having you on here is you know
most people that stop drinking they they
have been number one they're alcoholics
and maybe I don't know there's a
severity for
alcoholism but they're like most people
that quit drinking they quit drinking
cuz like they hit rock bottom right
that's a thing yeah got to hit rock
bottom and I would say you did not hit
rock bottom no but you realized how much
further you could go yeah you know it's
like you didn't have to fall out of the
tree to hit rock bottom but you looked
up and saw that there's a lot more
altitude to gain and you ain't getting
it if you're hitting the bottle every
night I believe so yeah so let's stay
clean everybody yeah I would say my
uh I like these little metaphors like
little VIs where you can kind of have
like a vision of it a Quantified like
vision and it's almost like alcohol is
this um is this little devil mhm that
and let's face it the devil can offer up
some cool things oh yeah you know devil
that's what they that's what the devil
does deal with the devil yeah exactly
the devil doesn't yeah the devil doesn't
offer you up things that look bad the
devil offers you up things that look
good you suckered in exactly right and
and no M and the more you justify it the
more the devil's like yes yes yes yes
you know you're like no no no but it's
not it's helping me in this creative way
or it's like it's not a problem you know
I do it to have more fun with my friends
build relationships you know all this
stuff with but the devil's in there
going yes yes yes exactly like more of
that more of that you know kind of a
thing but really what the devil is doing
it's is finding its way into the a bunch
of parts of your life in fact the more
the better the more parts of your life
that the devil can find his way into the
better for him and then his goal is to
just it all
up and the more you justify it the more
he's like yes yes allow me into to this
part too you know it's like yeah man
you're you're stressed right now I can
help you with that like let me help you
with your stress by the way put some
alcohol on your stress that'll help
that'll help you know it'll help for the
next hour you can't think straight you
forget about the fact that that stress
is there yeah then you wake up and the
stress is more oh yeah and then you know
what then you'll need me a little bit
more don't worry I'll be there I'll be
there for you until you die it's
true quit drinking out there there if
you're
drinking doesn't help you get some help
if you need it but the alcohol is not
going to do it um anything else Echo
Charles that's it hey look don't be
drinking that but you know what you can
drink you can drink one of these right
here you can drink you can drink some
Joo go you can drink some greens bro our
greens are good it's true and they give
you that they give you everything you
need joof fuel.com get some hydrate get
some go get some
MLK get everything that you need to
support your body
don't be mixing don't be mixing go with
alcohol by the way I know some people
have done it they call it a jock
Tail as opposed to a cocktail that
sounds cute for sure but kind of defeats
the purpose little bit we're not doing
that why even drink actually in a way
and hey no offense I'm not judging any
person because it gives you energy cuz
it gives you energy to get more wild but
we know why we drink this one instead of
the bad one because this one's better
for you yeah it tastes good you know all
this stuff and but you're kind of
defeating the purp if you're going to if
you're going to mix drinks I would
rather you at least have it the more
healthy version but I would really
prefer if you just didn't drink any
alcohol that's my recommendation I'll
tell you and there was a there was you
know we got a question on the
Underground a while ago and a guy
written in you know like can I just have
one or two drinks a month or whatever
yeah and I said you know what and it was
really in a time this is I don't know
maybe six months ago and I was I kind of
had an answer in my head of like listen
if you can drink you know have one or
two drinks not that big of a deal that's
normal and people carry on and and and I
just couldn't say it man yeah I just
couldn't say it I was like you know what
I just can't get behind alcohol I just
can't do it I've known too many people
that have lost too much in their lives
to alcohol yeah you know everything from
people that have you know spent all
their money people that have drank
themselves to death uh people that have
wrecked their relationships got divorced
end up killing themselves like it's a
terrible it it's such a huge part of all
all that negativity why do it why do it
and look if you're out there kicking ass
and you think yourself well I'm kind of
like Eko you know I still do my job I
still get everything done I can still
get a workout in it imagine how much
better you could be if you didn't have
that ball and chain around your ankle if
you didn't have that weight vest
on so don't do
it that's my recommendation I do
recommend joof fuel joof fuel.com you
can get it Wawa you can get vitamin shop
GNC military commissaries Apes Haner
Dash stor wake Fern shopright HB down in
TAS what's up Texas Tas we were just
down there for the muster oh outstanding
outstanding event uh Meyer up in the
midwest Harris to your Lifetime Fitness
Shields small gyms everywhere you know
you got a Jiu-Jitsu gym you got a
CrossFit gym you got a powerlifting gym
you want to get some joof fuel there
email JF sales joof
fuel.com also don't forget about if
you're training Jiu-Jitsu which you
should because it'll put a smile on your
face in many in manys sometimes it won't
we get that sometimes you're going to
get frustrated you might get a frown
here and there yeah you may just the D
the frowns or just the Doms of Jiu-Jitsu
the
mental y like sometimes you get really
mad doing Jiu-Jitsu you get caught you
do something stupid yeah I I'm gonna be
honest I've seen you well I've seen you
appear really mad yeah with Dean L A few
times yeah yeah yeah a few times um but
I don't know that I've ever felt really
actually mad and you just ever yeah even
when I got injured I I I was I was mad
that I was injured but I was mad if I'm
injured I was mad that but I was glad
I'm still doing Jiu-Jitsu though yeah
you know it's like the live by the sword
Die By The Sword kind of a feeling if
you want jao fuel there get uh go to JF
sales at joof field.com and if you need
jiujitsu gear wherever you are go to
origin usa.com if you need jeans
wherever you are if you need boots
wherever you are if you need t-shirts
hoodies rash gards whatever you need go
to origin usa.com and get americanmade
stuff don't support
communism don't support slavery don't
support child labor don't support poor
quality products support an americanmade
product that is of the highest
quality origin usa.com get what you need
oh yeah time also discipline equals
Freedom this is true it's true the more
disciplined you are the more free you
are cut the balling chain that's what it
is freaking balling chain um yeah but
you want to represent on this path where
we're on the path drinking or not
whether you chose to quit drinking yet
yeah or not we're still on the path you
want to represent Joost store.com
discipline equal Freedom good these are
good attitudes to have by the way um
that's where you can get your stuff hats
and hoodies shirts of course um also
this shirt Locker by the way I saw a lot
of representation at the muster from the
shirt
Locker Peaks a lot of PE other people's
curiosity yeah yep when they say yo yeah
you just made like a heavy metal-ish
looking one it's pretty dope yeah yeah
fully and so a lot of them are are like
this which I didn't realize but like
when I see everyone kind of with it it's
almost like you know we know discipline
equals Freedom we see you wearing the
you know the deal and um you'll see like
a new one they'll be like hey where'd
you get that one like that one's like
kind of cool like where'd you get that
one I never I didn't see that one before
but yeah that's kind of the phenomenon
in a way yeah good representation this P
for sure shirt Locker it's called the
shirt Locker it's on Joost store it's a
cool subscription you get a new one
every month uh you know a new new design
every month it's cool on Joost store.com
hey you might also need steak right you
might need ground beef go to colorcraft
beef.com freaking outstanding
outstanding
steak and also
Primal beef.com which is out in Virginia
the Shen andoa Valley so you got two
options right there to get yourself some
steak the they will deliver it to your
door and you can just Grill it up you
can throw it uh you can throw it in a
pan and cook it 2 minutes 2 minutes 2
minutes 2 minutes two minutes what is it
total of eight minutes and you probably
got yourself a solid steak right there
throw some pepper and some rock salt on
it watch your heat by the way yeah don't
get crazy don't get nuts yeah don't get
nuts on don't get nuts on the heat what
what heat would you say uh I would do a
medium wait wait do you put the the the
what do you call the top the cover yeah
the cover Noe cover okay no no no I do
the cover but then I just go one minute
one minute one minute one minute one
minute only four minutes yep but with
the top on okay cuz that's maintaining a
lot of heat cooking it from multiple
directions I think so yeah okay so you
know hey we all have our process check
those out uh awesome people awesome
companies that you can you can get into
and you can also eat some awesome food
so there you
go also subscribe to this podcast also
go to Joo underground.com And subscribe
to that alternative podcast also
psychological warfare Flipside
canvas.com but from Dakota Meer all the
different books that I've written check
those things out we have Echelon front
we just got back from the muster
thousand people there it's been sold out
for months the next one is in San Diego
if you want to come to it you got to go
register right now we solve problems
through leadership echelon front.com is
the website we also have online training
leadership is not something you can do
one time and now you know how to do it
just like you don't get in shape going
to the gym one time you got to go every
day so that's what we made the extreme
ownership Academy for extrem ownership.
comom you can go on there every day and
you can learn leadership and you can
review leadership and you can hone your
leadership skills so way you can handle
everything that's going on in your
business and in your life extrem
ownership. comom and if you want to help
service members active and retire you
want to help their families gold star
families check out Mark Le's mom mama
Lee She's Got an unbelievable charity
organization if you want to donate or
you want to get involved go to americaas
Mighty warriors.org also don't forget
about mic aink I just met a graduate
from the heroes and horses. org
program great individual from the Marine
Corps that had been through the program
was having some real issues going to to
the program comes out of the program
like a new
man so thanks to Micah think for what
he's got going on there also Jimmy May
has got an organization to help people
transition out of the military beyondthe
brotherhood.
org so check that out and if you want to
connect with us on the interwebs we're
on there Echo at EA Charles I'm at Jo
willings just watch out for the
algorithm because it's a monster and
it'll sneak up on you it'll probably
bring it probably serve you a beverage
to a drink an alcoholic drink yes just
get you to sit there and scroll drunk
and scrolling this is bad news don't let
it happen we'll see you on the on the
interwebs but we're not going to be part
of that algorithm and thanks to all of
our military personnel out there these
are tenuous times right now very tenuous
times the war drums are
beating and for us sitting back here in
America going oh we should do this and
we should do that
and it's all of you out there in uniform
that actually answer the call so thank
you for what you all do and also thanks
to our police law enforcement
firefighters paramedics EMTs dispatchers
correctional officers border patrol
Secret Service and all First Responders
thank you for answering the call here at
home and to everyone else out there I'm
going to give you some guidance from
lemi of
motohead another band that put some
bricks in the path for me and help me
out as a kid ly says so you see the only
proof of what you are is in the way you
hear the truth grab a hold don't let go
don't let them rob you of the only thing
you know oh no no one else got the right
to make you feel sorry for yourself stay
clean it's your only
hope so stay clean everyone and until
next time this is Ekko and Joo
out